all right uh we're going to go to the
fifth Li lift in air quotes there uh I
just don't have time to do the deadlift
and the and the back squats yet we'll
get there okay so this is the fifth one
and this fifth one is really
not uh necessarily a strength gaining
exercise like the other four R but we
use it uh for a couple reasons uh one
it's going to I your
biceps uh and in a fight uh you're you'd
rather have a strong arm than a weak
arms so this is a way of getting your
arms uh your forearms your grip strength
H your biceps and of course the lats uh
condition so I prefer the chinups over
the pull-ups uh because it hits more of
your fighting muscles than just your
your um your lats okay so we do the
chinups and then uh primarily though why
we use the chinups is it is indicating
or indicative of the quality of your
strength to weight ratio okay so um we
do have an objective strength goal but
we are not going to be weightlifters or
powerlifters that's not our Sport and
our sport is combat per se and towards
that end we have to prioritize ize uh
Mobility so we prioritize Mobility
slightly over strength and that means
that I can't just be this big huge
strong tubble Ard on the mat I got to be
agile and quick uh as well as strong so
chinups are very indicative of that and
what we deem as
acceptable is that you can do a 5x5 with
your chinups uh you'll see that we have
people at the dojo that are really wrong
and uh they might have to up this all
the way up to between 7 and 10 uh no
problem and I mainly don't want their um
I don't want too much rest from the
other exercises so for example if we
were doing a hit uh workout and they
could sit up here on chinups all day but
their legs are getting too much rest so
it's more like I don't like to see them
do more than seven or 10 in a hit
workout but we don't want to see less
than five so if we see that you're
working less than five you need to rest
in between five you're just too heavy uh
for your strength or the other way to
look at it is you're just too weak okay
so here's how we do the chinups first um
you're going to put your palms facing
you and your hands are shoulder width
apart so he's a little narrow there
there we go and they're what we call
strict chinups so don't do it yet he's
going to take all his weight off his
legs and hang at the bottom some elbow
flexion is fine because different joints
have different level of integrity and I
don't want anyone hyperextending okay uh
and then he'll go up with no Kipping at
all he'll just go straight up get his
chin over the bar with no Chin lifting
and then he comes back down for a set of
five so now you'll do it with me he'll
take his weight off his feet and then he
does strict five go and he's just going
he always comes back you got a little
too much elbow flexion there you go okay
and he would do that 5 by five so here
we'll have uh Ronin come in and he
weighs a a lot more uh I still think
he's relatively a lot stronger than
Tristan uh but he still has the capacity
easy to do this no
problem and then uh we'll have uh
Andrew I don't know where you at Andrew
to tell you the truth but for me you
could always get lighter and stronger so
let's see what we're doing here okay
one cool okay and then uh we'll as to
show how we use this as a metric for
strength to weight ratio uh Priscilla's
kind of gone iido light easy wait I'll
tell you when to start she's gone iido
light on me which is fine I'm not going
to make my kids do it do do iido uh hard
like me um she's old enough how old are
you Sila 24 she's 24 she hasn't figured
things out so she still thinks a life
without iido is a good life but she has
a base in her she uses the art all the
time but here you can see um let's see
where we at last time I saw you you were
so she didn't do it strictly that's
always a sign so you're going to take
your feet
off and then you
start okay so this this is uh
everybody's where they're at of course
but this is this would be indicative of
we're not meeting the desired goal here
and she knows that cuz uh she's spending
a lot of time working and things like
that getting ready to go to school but
last time you were training hard you
were able to do a lot a lot more of
those right I was still doing one at a
time okay one at a time but you're able
to do one okay um so we don't we want to
see those 5x5 as a minimum um and other
than that we're really not performing I
don't care you know how vegan you are or
whatever your your blood work is telling
telling you you're just not in the
ballpark for the Marshal side of the art
or the the hard regular training um
you're just out of the ballpark so you
got to get yourself in the ballpark and
chinups tell you where the ballpark is